Film Courage: How do you write a great scene?
Shannan E. Johnson, Writer/Instructor/Script
Consultant: I think you should look at your
scenes like you look at the whole screenplay
and figure out the cause and effect of what
does this scene cause to happen and how is
it the effect of what happened before it?
Understanding that in every scene there is
a goal just like there is in the entire screenplay.
The only reason we are seeing this scene is
because it’s getting you closer to or further
away from your goal.
If you look at it like there is a goal that
has to be reached so that you can get to the
next thing that gets to the next thing that
gets to the next thing.
Then you end up not having scenes that are
back to just regular activity instead of intentional
action or even considering from an actor’s
point of view when they are going to play
out that scene one of them is winning right?
Somebody is going to win in this thing (in
this scene) it’s kind of like it’s a fight.
Ding!
In this corner these characters are going
to come and whatever it is that they are saying
to each other someone is going to win emotionally,
someone is going to lose.
Someone might physically win, someone might
lose.
But what that means is now that emotional
journey that I was on has been changed.
Again, it’s the cause and effect.
So there might by a physical cause and effect,
it might be an emotional cause and effect
or it might be both.
But looking at the scenes like they are little
movies right?
Like what is it setting up for me?
What is the goal of this scene and then how
does it resolve to get me to the next thing.
Film Courage: So if we were going to take
the hypothetical female character who was
entering a singing contest, now she nows that
her mother needs this deposit to start treatment…so
that great scene is going to be her maybe
getting this news?
Then she knows that the contest is coming
up and all of the things she has to do to
prepare?
I don’t know…because the stakes have risen.
It’s not just “Oh I need it for my dorm
room.”
Or “I want to buy a nice purse.”
Shannan: Yes, so now her action because of
that scene, because of that new information,
her intentional action is going to change.
Maybe before then she wasn’t practicing
very much because she’s got a natural voice
you know?
She wasn’t practicing very much, she wasn’t
finding any new songs, she’s like “Oh
yeah, I’ll just go up there and I will sing.
Whatever, because every time I sing a song
it’s great.”
But now this thing has been a humbling moment
for her.
Now we are going to see her going to her lessons.
We’re going to see her trying to find the
best song, she is going to be putting a different
kind of action into it because now the stakes
are risen.
Now there is something more at stake so she’s
going to put a different kind of action into
it.
That thing is going to cause her to change.
Exactly.